on met la musique pour l'habituer au son
et que
ça la détend aussi un peu en même temps
chaque jour nana s'entraîne à la parade
au salon de l'agriculture son port de
tête ça marche et c'est 750 kg devront
faire bonne impression donc elle a 7 ans
elle s'appelle nana FLA elle a eu 4
chevaux c'est elle qui a été
sélectionnée pour aller à Paris
tant enfin et faire le concours lundi
c'est une tradition dans cette ferme
familiale le grand-père le père est
maintenant le fils sont fiers de
présenter les plus belles bêtes de leur
élevage ça peut donner un peu de valeur
à l'élevage et puis faire reconnaître
nos animaux et notre cheptel
[Musique]
ça se passera bien
et surtout passer un bon moment avec les
copains et puis avec notre fils pour
l'esthétique c'est maman qui est de bon
conseil nana a droit à un toilettage
complet pour préparer la vache pour le
salon et ben faut qu'elle soit bien
propre toute partout et puis là bah
qu'elle est blanche il faut que ce soit
bien blanc et pas jaune alors du coup il
fera ils vont frotter bien comme il faut
frotte frotte bien froide bien sur le
blanc là hop Anaïs
tu frottes bien et puis il faut que la
queue soit bien propre également
de la vache primolstein la médaille ce
sera peut-être lundi